[音楽]
2021年9月から昨年の7月まで僕は
派遣切り抑制としてイギリスに留学してい
ましたその経験から本日は学問の説明なら
も
留学のすすめとしてお話をしたいと思い
ます僕が保健されたのは英国債権
パブリックスクールミュージシャンという
学校でした実は慶應義塾の技術という言葉
はこのまさに英国のパブリックスクール
私立学校にあるそうです
どのような共通点があるのか
探ることを僕の留学生活の目的としました
実際1年間かけて100人近くの学校の
生徒先生卒業生の方と一対一で対話をし
600年以上の歴史を持つ学校のもっとの
本質を
探る日々を送っていました
詳しく内容は答えは割愛させていただき
ますがコミュニケーションはもっと直訳
するとまぁ人を作るといった意味はこの
モットーに乗ったり学業成績だけでなく
それぞれの制度の人格形成の目標を置いた
ベンチェスターの教育の目的本質を
面しそれこそが目的の目的との共通点が
あるのでは
考える福田先生は学問のすすめの冒頭で
賢人と愚人の差があるのは学ぶか学ばない
かなんてできる
学問の大切されましたがそれと同時に英国
のパブリックスクールを基本とした全人格
的な教育を目指されたそうですこのことは
先ほど文化冒頭で申し上げた慶應義塾の
目的にもはっきりと表れており特にこの
気品の宣言取得論破こそがインジェスター
のもっと通じるところがあるので僕は考え
ています
ちなみにこのもっとについてのリサーチは
プリン決済の成果を認めていただき学校の
年間心は卒業生代表としてインタビューし
ていただきましたその記事の中では僕自身
慶應義塾についてしっかりとお話しする
ことができ
刑務時間の派遣入学生としても務め
すなわちケアウィッグへの還元
恩返しが
合わせ方ながらでもできたのではないかと
考えて
いますこんな形で僕の一つの大きな目的は
達成された留学生活でしたがそれと同時に
本当にたくさん学ぶことがありましたここ
では2つご紹介できれば
と思います1つ目は留学をしたことに逆に
日本について考える機会がたくさんあり
ました16年間日本ですると育ってきてい
たため日本の文化や歴史についてはすでに
拡散していましたがそれらは海外の人々を
伝えれそれまた海外の人たちが日本につい
てどのように捉えているのかについて知る
ことができました
例えば地質についてプレゼンテーションを
した時にはその中でわびさびの概念の話と
安い詫びてわさびのことで本気でそんな
真面目な顔してきたんですそれから彼は
特に西洋人にとっては全く新しい日本の
文化財団を伝えるためには苦労しましたが
同時に大きなやりがいも感じていました
次のこの若干societyで立ち上げた
日本の文化
歴史を伝える活動でしたが例えば広島長崎
の原爆についてもセッションを行った際
そのセッションの前には僕自身一対一で
広島の
被爆3世の方で引退してお話を聞く機会を
設けていただきそういったプロセスの中で
自分がそれまで全然知らなかった日本に
ついて知ることもありました
そのプランの結果として自分が生まれ育っ
て日本という国そのものに対してより強い
ご利用を持ったことはすごく貴重な財産
だったしこれからは将来は日本を代表して
日本のために働きたい仕事が増えている
大きな夢を持つようになりました
2つ目は自分がいかに狭い世界で生きて
いるかを追加した人です
昨年の7月にイギリスからドバイにあたっ
て模擬国連に参加した機会がありました
100年近い中で日本人は僕一人高校生も
僕を含めて二人だけで大学では環境とか
調べて頑張っていたんですがその中で
岡山問題について議論があった際
インドネシア出身のある女性の方がその
移民問題を移民の人たちの立場で話して
くださいまし
それまでは先進国日本でずっと
恵まれた環境が育ってきた自分が全く知ら
なかった考え方がそこにあって
衝撃を受けました自分が今までいかに狭い
恵まれた世界でしか生きてこなかったと
痛感し同時にこれが今も意味問題
になってい
ますここまで留学生活についてお話しして
きましたがもしかしたらすごく簡単に
聞こえる見えるかもしれませんでも一つ実
は自分の中で大きな挫折があって今まで
18年間生きてきた中でもし一つ何か天気
を上げろと言われたらこの日になります
2020年の6月22日
この日は実行1年生の英語をクラス分け
試験結果発表でした実行では1年生の時に
上級クラスの標準化する英語2つに
分かれるんですが
例年よりコロナでちょっと
その2つに分かれるし僕は標準から
実は先ほどまでお話ししていたこの慶應
義塾の派遣切りはプログラム中学2年生で
初めてこの説明会に参加した時からずっと
憧れていてその時から自分なりに英語を
勉強に力を注いだったつもりでした
本当に悔しかったですとても
屈辱的な表現でした
でもそれをめげずにこの結果発表があった
ちょうど5日後には県入学のオンライン
説明会に参加しそこで挑戦することを決意
しました
初めて受けたトークの点数は50代にも
満たなかったのですがそこから2ヶ月間部
活動と両立させながら視力を尽くして勉強
しました
初めて自分が今まで積み上げてきたものを
全てぶつけるんだっていう覚悟を持って
文字通り試行錯誤しながら
立ち上げて12月に派遣に行くことになり
ました
日本にいる間にイギリスの生活に早く
始めるようにとたくさんいろんな準備をし
てました例えば今アーセナル
放送TBCに聞きまくってみたいあと日本
からイギリスに行く飛行機の中では自分の
自己紹介を英語でひたすら練習して
繰り返したりそういった努力もいざ
イギリスに行って寮に帰るともうみんな
入ってるから全然わかんないし自分が用意
してきた自己紹介するような機会がなく
挙句の果てには
置いてるんですけど入力した初日に
たまたまそのアースがサッカーチームの
アースナーのユニフォームした方がいて
ここしかない
チャンスだと思って
勇気を引き絞って相原明日の
母の聞いたすごい対応されて今は何だろう
ちょっとわかってないんですけどでもこう
いう女性がありながらも自分の地道な努力
で
そのチャンスを見つけたら挑戦すれば
そんな1年間だったなと思います
留学のすすめと台紙でお話ししてきました
がもしその中に少しでも留学を考えている
人がいればぜひ
挑戦してほしいしその先で見つかるかも
しれない壁も自分の自分の地道な努力で
あったり
今僕がお話ししたようなまた情けない
経験を少しでも思い出して
くださるとすごく
嬉しいですではまたこれは留学に限らず
この解放今回のテーマであり
解放っていう言葉自分をどっか新しい全く
新しい世界に開放してその新しい世界の
チャレンジを進めていくとそこで言われる
自分の新たな気づきだったり
もあるしそこで新しく仕上がり広がる曲の
間違いがあると思いますもし皆さんにも
そのような自分を解放できるしますぜひ
積極的に
挑戦してほしいし僕もこれからどんどん
チャレンジしていくつもりです
最後になりますが
昨年に
英国に
昨年以降から帰国してから実は自分の大学
の
悩んでましたその中で本当にたくさんの
実行の先生方を始めこの学校を卒業生の
方々だったり本当にたくさんのお話させて
いただいてお世話に乗っていただいたり一
つであった言葉があってこれは結婚卒業生
にこの学校の卒業生の方がご紹介していた
言葉を引用させていただきたいと思います
ここの桜のように
1年100回1回人をこんなにも喜ばせる
仕事ができればなんて思いました
日本の美しさ美の象徴とも言われる世界中
の人々を魅了しています僕もその一人です
12年前の今日3月11日東日本であの
ような大震災があっても甲子園として植え
られた桜の花は人々を勇気づけ希望となり
続けたそうです
僕たちは大学に行ってそれぞれみんな違う
学問を学ばないいざ社会に解放されたら
それぞれの分野で先頭車たるものを目指し
ていくことになりますがもしそれぞれの
扇動者に共通するものを全ての受験に
求められているものがあるとすればこの桜
の花のように周りの人家族を元気にし
弾いては全社会がより良くしていけるよう
な人間になるのかもしれませ
ん
設けていただきありがとうございました
終わりますご清聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]